jess what are the three things you look
for in a husband and what ideologies do
you disagree with
from me
oh okay
whoo um
the three
um
tall because i'm i'm a tall girl i'm a
tall i'm tall
i'm like
i wanna i want somebody tall whatever um
but
whatever
at least at least six six foot plus i'm
not i'm not as tall as pearl
unfortunately i'm in the five foot range
but i'm in the high caliber
range
um
so tall and then um ambition
in all areas um
whether that's ambition to work out
towards your career whatever that may
look like towards relationship family
all that ambition i need you to want
something for your life before i get
into it because if i'm the only person
or if i'm like the thing you want in
life what else what else do you want
because
i wasn't there all the time and then um
probably the same
values as me there's so many you say the
same thing yeah
yeah
because i could be nitpicking but he
gotta be funny he gotta do this that and
third but like the overarching thing the
overarching things is i would like for
him to be tall
ambition and
the same values because i feel like if
all those are aligned and
um
equal then
other things will come
i should have put no kids yeah yeah yeah
so what do you disagree with from the
red pill
i don't i don't know because i feel like
i'm still like she's still learning and
so
um
i don't know because there's been things
that initially i'll be like oh
how dare you and then i like sit on it
and i think about it i'm like hmm
you have a point
and so it's the red pill for women in
like a nutshell yeah like the audacity
but then you listen and you're like oh
yeah
i forgot what you had said something one
time and i was like okay whatever pearl
like you don't know what you're talking
about and then i thought about it
afterwards and i was like
she has a point she has a point why is
you arguing the other point the next
challenge yeah yes yes you did it was
the men are better than women at
basketball men are better than women at
basketball you like freaked out yeah i
was like how dare you and then i thought
about them like your face was so funny
we're gonna react to it this week
um we just got a 50 dollar cool
look at guys you don't even understand
these super chats are so important to
the show like we cannot do equipment
upgrades without the super chat so i i
seriously i know you guys there's a lot
of people that watch for free
sorry i look this way there's a lot of
people that watch for free
and no one even has to send money at all
so the people that do like i it
thank you i appreciate it so much um
okay
um
um question oh gosh there's a lot more
super chats okay
oh wow pretty duper chats oh wow okay
okay um phillip pearl i remember you
calling kevin samuels for advice and i
just found your podcast salute for your
success
um just as a um bowsey justice you got a
little crush just as a solid 8
10 needs to be upgraded to the middle of
the stop
there right now
um
xanax regarding pearls of parents with
ali and coco what does the panel think
love is and let should love be pursued
or something that you fall into oh my
gosh guys you have so many panel
questions um question for the panel
should people
fight slash are you in a relationship or
not because most lasting successful
marriages last you to having arguments
and disagreements um zentan says fifty
dollars um stop blaming childhood or
outside factors for your current
situations if you claim to be an adult
self-reflect get help and self-improve
not doing it not doing so perpetuates a
victim mentality improve yourself before
asking others to do the same dang okay
um okay we'll do one or two more
questions
um
i'll do i'll do question for the panel
um should people fight and argue in a
relationship or not because most lasting
successful relationships have fights
so do you think being like if you want a
long marriage do you think fighting is
okay personally i don't
like fighting not fighting not at all
like if you have different
uh opinions about something
and if it does come to a point that you
start to talk and guess into a fight i
think it's
one of them it's smart enough like to
leave you know the room and not getting
to a physical or emotional
like really you know up there and then
people just explode and no i think one
should leave
i feel like
we're only human yeah you know
you might find exactly you might not
find it's just the way that you
communicate and deal with whatever
disruptions occurring in your
relationship so should people fight well
no but we're only human so i just feel
like in a long marriage you're gonna
there's gonna be years where you don't
really that's what i'm saying it's
duration you can't just like vouch on uh
are we supposed to fight or not because
it's duration it can happen any day you
can't just be like oh today i wake up
and i wouldn't fight at any cost but
then you end up fighting over coffee you
never know
because it's just like life you're
spending so much time with that person
and you get to know the person better
when you spend more time with them in
the same roof so
that's that's about it yeah i feel like
when you have disagreements sorry um
you can go at it two ways like some
people they say in in fights like in
battles like sometimes you're either
fighting for to win or you're fighting
for peace you know
so sometimes like
you fight like just because you want to
be right like you just want to win the
fight but like if you approach it from
that way like it's always going to be a
losing battle you know you have to fight
for peace you have to look to resolve
the issue rather than you know just
trying to prove that you're yeah exactly
you have to put your ego aside and like
truly because even though yeah you might
have moments in the marriage where you
don't like each other and you have to
accept that like you'll go through those
cycles
but it's like what do you really want at
the end of the day like
you want peace like that's what you
should strive for
i think i think fighting is important in
a relationship and the key is how you
repair after the fight yeah it's how you
mend the relationship after if you have
a fight and then go to bed like on
opposite ways without resolving the
issues at hand after you fought then
you're going to have problems within
your relationship
i like i feel like you should go to bed
angry
what why would you have a like i just
think when you're angry you say things
you regret so i'd rather just like cool
off maybe go to bed and like talk about
it the next day when we're both calm so
sleeping in the same bed like
i mean i think if it's like you go to
sleep in a different like if you have a
really bad fight like i would rather
cool off because i don't want to say
anything i regret because i'm angry and
emotional and i know as a woman like we
get emotional so i like my mama has a
rule where she told me growing up to if
you still are mad about it after two
days then say something but like
if if
in two days you don't care it probably
wasn't that important no i agree i think
more so my main point of emphasis is
just how you go about repairing after
the fight so it doesn't have to be
straight after it can be a cool down but
more so how do you repair your
relationship after the fight
because some people don't even repair
after a fight they
have a fight they go on about it and
there's no fixing it and they have
another fight and it's built off of the
brokenness of this fight in this fight
in this fight and it just
builds up until
years later someone's bringing up
something that happened years ago and
you're like i thought you were over that
no i was never over it he's like well
why didn't you talk about it
and also just thinking about someone
taking the lead to resolve the the issue
it's not like you're less important or
you don't have respect or
you have less ego or anything it just it
makes you
it makes you a better person in your own
eyes that yes you took something to
resolve it so whoever is resolving the
issue is they can delete resolve the
issue she didn't think that oh my god
now she would be thinking or he'll be
thinking that i don't have ego or i'm
i'm less important or something like
that because thanks to you the problem
would be resolved